hello everyone this video will be a bit
different than all my previous videos as
this is the chest time machine and the
chest time machine is something that was
created by chess club live I will put
all the needed information in the
description below so you can check it
out more for yourselves
but basically what the chess time
machine allows you to do is well you can
see chess games played between players
who never actually played as well they
either just never played together or
they were from different eras I mean you
can you can check out games between for
example Lasker and in Carlsen you can
check out games between
capablanca and Carlsen you can watch
games between Fisher and Morphy
basically any chess player they have in
their database you can compare the two
and just you know play out a game and
well in short how this works is well
first the engine has a database and for
example I chose a game Bobby Fischer
against Garry Kasparov and well the
engine knows every position Bobby
Fischer ever had in front of him and it
also knows every position Garry Kasparov
had in front of him and well as the
longest there well as long as they are
playing by theory the engine doesn't
turn on and as soon as one player runs
out of theory then the engine turns on
and then the engine starts playing so as
as I as I understand not all games were
played using the same engine so some
engines engines were stronger some were
weaker but all in all it was a fair
fight and I chose this game because it
seemed like the most interesting game I
only checked a couple of them I'm sure
there are a lot more interesting games
and one other thing it seemed the most
human-like so let's see this game this
is a Bobby Fischer with the white piece
against agaricus par with the black
pieces we have efore by Bobby and power
plays c5
so the Sicilian defense we have Knight
to f3 and
six d4c Kaptur sandy for nightcap sure
sandy for and Knight to f6
we have Knight to c3 by Bobby and d6
back is part of the Scheveningen
variation and okay Kasparov did play a
lot of Scheveningen in his days and this
is all correct so far let's see what
Bobby plays in this position Bobby plays
G for the Charis attack and it's quite
interesting the Bobby Fischer actually
did play quite a lot of games using the
caret stack and I found one of his games
it was from 1960 against my door for
disposition rose and in this position I
have continued with the move a six but
as a cusper never had this position
played in front of him he went a knight
to c6 so we have g5 attacking the knight
and that goes to d7 and now Knight d2 b5
attacking this d6 pawn so this has to be
defended the power plays a knight to c5
and now the bishop and the Queen are
protecting the d6 pawn and we have a
Bishop to e3
we have b6 and now really protecting
that night and preparing to develop the
light-square bishop and the Fischer goes
for f4 we have h6 and Queen to h5 and of
course now the point cannot be captured
as it's been the rook is hanging so
power plays g6 we have a Queen to h4 and
now wrote the g8 and Fischer castles
Queen side we have 8 captures on g5 and
now Fischer doesn't recapture the pawn
but he plays a queen to h7 and now he's
attacking this rook and g8 Kasparov has
the defendant so rocked the g7 attacking
the Queen and now Queen to h8 and this
winter h8 move is coming with a great
threat as now the bishop is paint and
cannot help with the defense of the d6
pawn so Knight to d6 order up to d6 are
all happening we have a night to be 7 by
Kasparov defending that d6 pawn and the
Fischer captures it Knight captures on
d6 we have 98% e6 and now Knight the b5
and well this night is still pinned so
now
there's a double attack on this night we
have Bishop to d7 and well cause power
couldn't really defend this night so we
have a knife capture sandy six boots
check we have team to e7 and we have F
captures in g5 we have Quinta c7 and
Bishop to b5 rook to d8 and rook stage
to f1 and now we have Knight to e5 going
for the exchange of this light square
bishop but as far back as sorry Fischer
actually plays Bishop to f4 and humans
to exchange his light square bishop for
this knight on e5 so we have Bishop
captures on b5 and Knight captures a
Bishop captures on e5 and attacking both
rook and well kind of harassing this
Queen and c7 we have Bishop captures on
f1 and now not capturing the rockin g7
or the bishop on f1 he plays a bishop to
f6 check so only move for as part of his
King to be 1837 and now we have this
Knight captures on f7 check and in this
position
Kaspar resigned as well he does have to
play something and after a move like
King to c8 simply rook captures rook
after sandy eight would check and this
is all over
so yeah this is the game this is the
game straight out of the time machine
and I'm very interested to hear your
opinion and this how do you think I mean
what do you think would would happen if
if these two did meet and how precise do
you think this this engine could could
achieve the experience of these two
great players so yeah I do hope you
enjoyed it and like I said you can check
the links in the description below so
you can check all the games for
ourselves and if you if you did enjoy
this time machine experience please do
tell me in the comments so I will try to
feature a couple of more games and you
were welcome to suggest a couple of
games if if you if you find them
interesting
in the database so yeah pretty pretty
much that's it for this video I do hope
you enjoyed it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here and thank all
for watching I will see you soon